Let's go next to our caller from the five
zero two area code.
Who's calling today from five zero two
Jackie.
Hey Jackie, what's up?
Mmm.
I guess my question is, in your opinion,
um, what,
what would be the consequences, if any, for
all the senators who have left the floor during
this,
you know,
impeachment trial or we're doing crosswords
or fell asleep.
I mean, is there any repercussions if any?
And isn't that why the chief justice is there?
Yeah, so chief justice John, so, so what Jackie's
referring to is that on, which was day three
of the trial, officially at one point 21 Republican
senators were just gone from this, from their
seats.
And a couple of them were stretching their
legs.
But as, as a Michael McCall posted on Twitter,
he was in the chamber.
A lot of them were just out.
They missed the evidence.
And how are you to decide whether to acquit
or convict Trump if you don't even see the
evidence?
So chief justice John Roberts presides over
the trial.
He is there in a procedural role, not to render
an opinion, but it's procedural.
And that includes enforcing the rules that
are established there.
So should there be some consequence if the
senators just leave?
Yes, there should.
What should it be Jackie?
I don't know.
I mean, is it a, is it a mistrial?
Is it what?
I don't know what the consequence should be,
but the most important takeaway is the one
you're pointing out, which is there's not
going to be any consequence.
They'll just all vote to acquit and then we'll
move on and pretend they'll pretend it was
a fair trial.
Yeah.
And it's, I don't know, it's just all really
discouraging.
I've always believed in the, um, the Dustin
system in this country.
I served my country, uh, and then I was a
police officer and I've always been in public
service and, um, it's just, it's just the
see the justice system do this and it's just
very disheartening and depressing, honestly.
Yeah, I mean the, the one thing that may be
a blessing in disguise is hopefully enough
people will realize the Mueller investigation
impeachment 25th amend, none of this stuff
is going to remove Donald Trump.
So if we want to remove them, we have to vote
in such overwhelming numbers in November.
That foul play can't get them reelected.
That's the one path and it should be very
clear to all of us now.
Well, yeah, I mean, and I understand, um,
I guess I have another question.
What would your suggestion be to someone like
me who lives in Kentucky?
Uh, where Mitch McConnell is my Senator, um,
on getting people out to vote.
Like my age group.
I'm 33, so my age group, um, you know, what
would be your, your suggestion as you know
how to best do this.
So campaigns, there's a lot of campaign strategy
campaigns, know how to get people out to vote,
uh, volunteer for Amy McGrath.
And, uh, I think that Mitch McConnell also
has another challenger.
But in any case, figure out who has the best
shot of defeating Mitch McConnell volunteer
and work on, get out the vote.
They, the the campaigns know the right, get
out the vote strategies, how to identify the
right people and volunteer and just work to
remove Mitch McConnell.
That's the, at least in the for the next nine
months, that's what I would be doing.
Yeah.
Um, you know, I, I don't anymore, I'm a stay
at home mom and so I do have a bit of free
time.
So that is what I am devoting the next nine
months to is making sure that McConnell's
gone
well.
That's a good strategy.
I that that's, that's we've got to be working
more at the state level for sure.
And I think that's a great idea, Jackie.
I just don't always feel like at the state
level I'm, I'm making 'em as much of a difference
as I don't know other places.
No, I think that's a fallacy.
So anybody at any individual state level could
say that, but if everybody in every state
actually got together, the impact would be
absolutely, absolutely massive.
Jackie, I'm going to let you go.
I really appreciate the phone call and, and
uh, uh, let's check back in.
If you do indeed start volunteering there
and working to get Mitch McConnell out, I'd
be interested in hearing how that all goes.
Let's go next to our caller from the two five,
six area code.